let's talk about this report that came
out from
the afl-cio which is the largest labor
union um federation here in the united
states and it's looking at ceo
compensation this is we've been looking
at for a few years now so let's get
let's get to it because it's getting
quite the reaction especially on social
media so you can see here that the ceo
the average ceo made 324 times more than
the median workers in 2021 that is
according to their report this is their
executive pay watch
report and they're calling it
greed inflation so they point out that
corporate profits are up
ceo pay is up but real wages are down um
they call ceos not working they said
ceos not working people are causing
inflation so here's the narrative here
um but yeah i hear the economics of
green inflation and how it compares to
real worker wages so
this is a classic classic right here i
just want to make sure that i got this
right
in this chart
they're saying that the real worker
wages
went down
the nominal worker wages went up but i
don't see anywhere in there where they
show the real
ceo pay all right let's dig into it or
the real corporate profits i'm just
going off their report i'm presenting
this report we're going to get your
reaction go ahead okay so according to
the afl cio they said working people's
real wages fall while ceo pays source
they said in 2021 corporate ceos were
quick to blame worker wages for causing
inflation but workers real wages
actually fell 2.4 percent in 2021 after
adjusting for inflation where can people
experience a pay cut for with every
price increase while u.s companies
enjoyed record profits and ceo pay
increased even at an even faster rate so
that's what they say about that chart
here we go greenflation by the numbers
in 2021 ceos of s p 500 companies
received an average of 18.3 million in
total compensation ceo pay rose 18.2
faster than the u.s inflation rate of
7.1
in contrast u.s worker wages fell behind
inflation with worker wages rising only
4.7 in 2021
um the average s p 500 companies ceo to
work or pay ratio was 324 to 1.
runaway ceo pay is a symptom of greed
flation that they got
when companies increase prices to boost
corporate profits and create windfall
payouts for corporate ceos pump i know
you have a reaction come on
i i feel like uh trying to oppose uh or
diabolically uh compare i think i don't
know marriage that we're wrong uh ceo
pay and worker pay is dumb
why don't you just say workers should
get paid more so that their real working
wage goes up rather than down it's
actually what does it have to do with
ceo pay and look this is the thing that
this is the kind of framing that's
always going to get the headlines
because it's like look at these greedy
ceos and compared to that this is so
this is socialism the most important
data there though is that real worker
wages haven't increased but maybe if you
just took out that single point versus
doing the comparison to the ceos hey
inflation is crushing the average
american like when your grocery bill is
up 12.2 percent that is just insane the
average uh employee is not as valuable
as the ceo yeah like again people get
mad but like that's just the truth
that is totally fair and i i think again
this is one of those things that's like
everyone's going to pile on on social
media that's fine the people on the
internet are stupid like duh right and
guess what that's why the internet is
the internet because there's some smart
people there's some dumb people and they
all yell at each other like that makes
up the internet it's amazing this is
awesome the other thing with
compensation and i you have to kind of
understand like how does it work a lot
of it is stock based or it's like
performance
it's it's not like oh here's um 18
million dollars good job like it's tied
to
the equity at the end of the day here's
what people don't like
the average worker is more valuable to a
company than the ceo the ceo many would
argue is the single most valuable person
to that business
if you want to get paid more money
create more value and if you work in a
role and you're not getting paid enough
money my guess is given that there's 11
million open jobs in america if you have
value to create and provide to a
business you can leave and go to another
job and they will pay you more money
that's how a free market works how
capitalism works but
on top of that if you are the worker and
you're 100
cash and you don't have stock it's no
different than personal finance you
cannot get wealthy by just holding cash
you have to have investable assets in
today's society because you cannot save
your way to financial security so what
you should be asking for is one of three
things i need upside in the form of some
sort of revenue share a profit share or
i need equity one of those three things
that's what you should be asking for now
that doesn't mean that they're going to
give you a ton but any amount ends up
being a very important component of it
now on top of that another key component
of this is that the ceo pay as julia
pointed out is drastically tied to the
performance of the business
nobody ever talks about uh when elon
musk got paid all that money
if they put in all these performance
bonuses and the company never hit them
no one would have ever talked about it
the reason why they put them in there
was it was sounded insane at the time
sure we'll give you a billion dollars if
you hit you know whatever valuation of
the business sure elon
and then he went and did it he bet on
himself
now
the other piece of this
is that individuals
100 percent
should consider if you the skill set the
interest and the ability
if you want to get paid like the ceo go
do the ceo job and the best way to do
that is to go start a business and if
you are successful then you will end up
getting paid whatever you want you're
the boss you you get where you can work
your way up to the top did you know that
the walmart ceo started as an hourly
associate
i think you started in the one of what
the either the us ceo there so there's
the like the whole walmart ceo and then
there's the usco they both started as
hourly associates one was loading trucks
so i think that's doug mcmillan the
other was working in the garden center
so they've started a story it's possible
i don't think that that's the path most
people should take because not for
everyone because what happens is uh for
every one person who made it who's the
person who uh wasn't kevin meyer i think
was uh the disney guy uh kevin mayer he
was the uh second in command it was him
and the new the new bob yeah bob chepic
or whatever and they were sitting and
they were vying it was corporate
politics who's gonna be the new ceo and
he got passed over and then he left and
he went to tic toc was there for like a
week and then he left there and so what
ends up happening is like he worked his
way up right uh gets there
and just gets passed over and so when
you look at that it's like yes you could
try to do that
my whole mantra and approach it's just
bet on yourself literally go bet on
yourself and by the way not everyone is
made to be a ceo a founder not everyone
wants to do that all that i get it
that's fine
but
the risk that people take and the work
that they do is usually aligned with the
value they create i could make a very
strong argument that elon musk is
underpaid i can make a very strong
argument that jeff bezos is underpaid
now
i think that it doesn't really matter
because they get so much money like
whatever right but i also and a key
piece of this is the average workers
underpaid as well and so that's the
claim like if that's what they're
worried about which it's a union of
course that's what they're worried about
the approach of will you make more money
than me so we should make more money
is dumb
right because guess what i can make a
bigger argument than them in two seconds
hey inflation is 9.1 percent in america
you only raise our wages 4.7 you're
paying us less money we need more
because like you don't talk about ceo
just literally say pay us more money and
we should get a 12 raise because we're
literally getting paid less because of
high inflation high inflation that's a
good point because usually it's like the
typical i've worked in corporate america
where it's like oh you get the three
percent raise each year to keep up with
inflation but yes you should make a
stronger argument on
it's not keeping up with inflation right
now um you mentioned jeff bezos i don't
know if the guys have it but this is the
example they break out here i don't know
if you want to see it pump but they
point to the amazon ceo as their as
their target of course look these people
are just looking for uh ways to get
headlines there you go with the andy
andy jassy's
uh compensation that's what they break
out but here's the craziest part amazon
so like they're going after amazon right
they claim that amazon's median worker
pay is 32 000
all this stuff right if i google right
now amazon hourly wage
this is the part that i just like wait
what are you talking about uh frequently
asked questions about amazon.com this
comes from payscale.com
they pay their employees an average of
17.59 an hour
it ranges the lowest that amazon pays is
14.45 the highest is 29 an hour there
are people who are literally talking to
politicians begging begging politicians
please pass 15 an hour amazon was
leading that conversation yeah
the free market jeff bezos already
outperformed the politicians
jeff bezos pays
17.59 an hour
why aren't the politicians able to do it
because the free market ends up doing it
beforehand that is capitalism and
literally the politicians are yelling
and screaming about 15 an hour well why
don't we make it 17.59
why only 15
why so bearish
instead
jack it up let me ask you this um
because it makes me wonder like what
like it's what is the goal of this is it
okay let's raise awareness and boost
worker wages or is there another side of
it like cap ceo pay what would be the
consequences if you had i don't know
like if that's even possible because
yeah we're talking about free market
here you can't really do i don't know
what would be the consequences of of
that well but like it just throws off
the market like literally just let it be
a free market what we end up finding is
there's 11 million open jobs in america
10 and a half million whatever it is
yeah guess what people want somebody to
come work there and if they say okay
i'll pay 12 dollars and no one shows up
guess what they do fine i'll pay 13.
okay nobody shows up 14 15 16.
amazon is paying 17 and 59 cents an hour
on average and guess why because they
have to
if you went to them and said hey by the
way the market will allow you to pay 14
they pay 14
but that's not what the market is the
market is higher because they can't get
enough people to come work there so they
have to keep raising the price
that's how the game is played that's how
free markets work and so the second that
you step in and you start to um cap
compensation
you're just manipulating the market you
throw it all off by the way if ceos are
bad they get fired true if the
government stops stepping in you want
like if they really wanted to go after
ceos go rail against the government that
bailed out all the companies that were
going to fail during covet why did we
give 25 billion to the airline industry
when they were bankrupt like it was over
game over it was over that was remember
chamath's um cnbc segment on that yes it
was over the airlines were done and the
ceos that led those businesses and
didn't have the strong balance sheets to
survive that situation because they'd
done stock buybacks for last decade
should have been out it should have been
over yeah and guess what the planes
wouldn't have stopped flying they would
have put everything all the assets into
bankruptcy and there would have been new
people who came in took those assets
they would have recapitalized the
business and they would be off to the
races again that's not what happened
instead the government stepped in they
gave them 25 billion dollars in one of
the slugs i think there was a second
slug as well and two-thirds of it they
just said don't worry about you don't
pay us back
you know it's not debt it's not equity
it's just a gift
yeah like we everyone watched it we paid
for that
we propped up bad businesses
but hey we're gonna go after the ceos of
these other companies that are good
businesses they're probably on this list
too um let's keep going so this is what
they also say ceo pay matters this is
their other segment they say the ratio
of co to worker pay is important a
higher pay ratio could be a sign that
companies suffer from a winner take off
philosophy where executives reap the
lion's share of compensation a lower pay
ratio could indicate the companies that
are dedicated to creating high-wage jobs
and investing in their employees for the
company's long-term health but i don't
think that the wage is the only way that
people measure the investment in their
people for example walmart
is famous walmart i believe sends um
what is it their college plan they have
they do have a they it was a dollar
tuition but they they have a whole
college tuition reimbursement
in in july of last year walmart
announced they are going to pay 100
of college tuition and books for
associates they're going to invest
nearly 1 billion over 5 years for
career-driven training and development
100 of college tuition and books for
their associates can i tell you more
about that i actually covered this so it
used to be um
it used to be their dollar um it was
like you pay a dollar just have a little
skin in the game i forgot what it worked
i was like a dollar a week or something
whatever it turned out to be yeah so
it's just a little skin game but now
that yes they've opened up that benefit
and not only are they doing these
different colleges they also have more
vocational and technical training for
their associates too which is really
important they are the largest private
employer in the united states with like
i think one point million people work
for walmart and 90 of the us population
lives within 10 miles of a walmart i
grew up in a rural part of virginia and
like i live 11 miles from the walmart
but i think that's part of it like that
doesn't show up in the worker uh to ceo
or if you look at um starbucks for
example i we were talking about them the
other day but they are probably like the
quintessential example they were the
first i believe i think they were the
first to do the tuition reimbursement
for their um for their partners is what
they what they call their retailer and
to be clear i'm not arguing that uh
we shouldn't pay workers more i'm
actually arguing the opposite i'm just
saying that the way to make the argument
is not the ceo to worker ratio right
that is uh that is the argument that is
made by people who don't understand
economics that is the argument that is
made by people who do not understand
business it's by think tanks by unions
by all these people who do not
understand the market
instead
you can make the same exact argument in
terms of what you're trying to
accomplish which is we should pay
workers more money i agree with that
i've been literally every single day
that's all i talk about is that if you
have not gotten a raise of more than 9.1
percent over the last 12 months or you
do not have some sort of upside in your
job you're getting paid less money today
than you were a year ago yeah
so i mean at one point we even did a
whole tutorial on how to go ask for a
raise okay i was gonna say here's how i
did it because i used to struggle with
this and i'd always like you know put my
head down do my work like have great
performance numbers but i was like i
never asked and i would kind of mention
i would want this role so it was
actually i'm not gonna say who it was um
there was a ceo who gave me great advice
and he'd like write it into a memo and
like i showed him the memo i'd worked on
another ceo so it was like two different
ceos and one was like take this out too
much emotionally so i wrote this like
boss memo and i like walked into the
room and i said i did this this and this
and this and this and i'd like this role
in this race and i just slid the memo
across the desk and then guess what i
got it and then i cried afterward
because i was like wow why did it take
so long why was i so scared i should
have asked for this for like years ago
there's a balance right because i think
some people are too scared to ask like
in this situation right and then once
they do it usually people are like yeah
of course we'll pay more money
but then there's other times
but there's other people who they ask
every [ __ ] month yeah i've seen that
they're like i'm gonna go ask for a
raise right now so there's a balance of
like uh if people really are thoughtful
about it yes there are times to ask for
and a way to ask for it to your point uh
but you got to be careful like if
somebody just asks every single month
you're just like you know they're yeah
look i talked to a lot of founders i
talked to a lot of ceos
and that's probably the number one thing
is they'll be
talking to an employee and like i even
there's one specific ceo i know who's
like i'm giving them feedback like you
must improve you're not doing well like
like we're going to put you on an
improvement plan and at the end of the
conversation it's like hey i need more
money
oh and while they're getting the pa
the pip or whatever you call it yes
performance improvement plan yeah it's
just like come on just uh uh just make
sure that you uh uh it now last thing i
want to say about all this uh before we
move on is um
workers in the united states of america
are getting screwed right now that's the
only thing probably me and the union
group agree on is that workers are on
real wage bases are getting paid less
money that's wrong right people should
go and should go try to raise wages now
part of the problem for most of these
companies is that if inflation is 9.1
percent and you haven't jacked up your
prices 9.1 percent
you actually will be making less money
already and then if you also then try to
move your worker pay up 9.1 percent
the economics of the business get thrown
off and they're almost not able to do it
so high inflation this is less about
greed this is inflation is uh throwing a
huge wrench into a lot of these
businesses where they're saying like
hey we didn't we don't want inflation
right we don't want to deal with this uh
but the worker is getting paid less
money and the worker should be paid a
commemorant uh increase with inflation
the problem is
inflation six months ago was seven
percent yeah now it's 9.1 so the
business can't like hey every single
month let's wait for the cpi print okay
let's go raise we don't even know we've
reached peak inflation at this point so
if they get a 9.1 percent inflation that
inflation goes to 12 percent everyone's
gonna be on the screen like i should
give a 12 rate like it's a moving target
but businesses i mean we saw last year
blackrock and the number of these
companies give eight percent raises and
stuff like that now those are wall
street firms they obviously have a very
good understanding of the economic
situation whatever but i do think that
that is the strongest argument these
folks have is the real worker wages down
we should change that and so that means
that people should get a raise how that
happens each company is different uh
what is the way to affect that change
again i don't think it's saying oh
agreed flation or yelling at the ceos or
whatever because i think a lot of people
just say like the conversation gets
focused on the ceos not on the actual
issue which is that the workers aren't
getting paid enough and so let's go
raise their so what they are saying
though before we close they they're
saying that the ceo basically got a
raise of 2.8 million from the previous
year i guess that's their average s p
500 ceos my guess is it's because uh
stock-based compensation and asset
prices exploded i would love to see them
recalculate it now with the current
stock prices uh and maybe it will go
down yeah when they do the 20 yeah the
2022 report because this is all about uh
last year's data
it's uh it's a wild wild world all right
where can we send people to find you on
the internet you can find me on twitter
uh my handle's julia laroche hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time